♪
JACKIE: WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SUNDAY SHOW."
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION KEEPS
BLAMING PUTIN FOR RECORD HIGH
INFLATION, BUT SOME IN THE MEDIA
ARE FINALLY ADMITTING WHAT WE
HAVE KNOWN ALL ALONG, IT'S
BECAUSE OF BIDEN.
LISTEN.
>> IF YOU ROOK AT THE NUMBERS,
INFLATION REALLY STARTED TO RISE
ALMOST EXACTLY WHEN BIDEN CAME
INTO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I DON'T THINK PEOPLE,
CANDIDLY, DON'T.
WE REMEMBER THAT INFLATION WAS
GOING ON LONG BEFORE TO SORT OF
WHITEWASH WHAT HAPPENED LAST
YEAR I DON'T THINK IS GOING TO
WORK FOR THEM POLITICALLY.
JACKIE: RACHEL, I FEEL LIKE A
BROKEN RECORD, BUT THEY ARE
SAYING IT TOO.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS IT'S
RIDICULOUS.
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL: SO, FIRST OF ALL, AS A
CONSERVATIVE, IT'S JUST SO
LAUGHABLE WHAT A LIGHT TOUCH
THEY HAVE --
[LAUGHTER]
WITH THEIR CRITICISM.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A CONSERVATIVE
IN YEAR ONE HAVING THIS ENTIRE
DISASTER INCLUDING INFLATION
WHICH HITS EVERYBODY ESPECIALLY
THE POOR AND THE MIDDLE CLASS
AND THOSE ON FIXED INCOME AND
GETTING THAT KIND OF A LIGHT
TOUCH.
THAT SAID, PERHAPS WHAT THEY'RE
DOING HERE IS ALLOWING FOR VISIT
SCHISM -- CRITICISM IN ORDER TO
ALLOW FOR ANOTHER CANDIDATE.
KAMALA WILL BE TIED TO BIDEN,
AND THEY JUST WANT TO MOVE 'EM
ON, ADMIT THAT SO MAYBE SOME OF
THE DEMOCRATS RUNNING IN THE
MIDTERMS DON'T GET TOO SMEARED
WITH ALL THE MUCK AND ALSO MAKE
ROOM FOR A NEW CANDIDATE IN
2024.
JACKIE: YEAH.
I WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT IN THIS
MONTAGE BECAUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS POINTING THE
FINGER AT PUTIN, AND THIS IS
LAUGHABLE TOO.
>> PUTIN'S WAR IS ALREADY
HURTING AMERICAN FAMILIES AT THE
GAS PUMP.
>> IT IS ACCURATE THAT THE
INVASION BY PRESIDENT PUTIN INTO
UKRAINE HAS IMPACTED GLOBAL
INFLATION, INFLATION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> NEXT MONTH WE'LL SEE FURTHER
EVIDENCE OF AN IMPACT ON U.S.
INFLATION OF PUTIN'S WAR ON
UKRAINE.
>> MAKE NO MISTAKE, INFLATION IS
LARGELY THE FAULT OF PUTIN.
JACK JACK CHARLIE, YOUR TAKE ON
THIS.
IT STARTED WHEN THEY STARTED,
YOU KNOW, SIGNING THESE BILLS TO
SPEND TRILLIONS AND TRILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT AMERICA DIDN'T NEED
AT THAT TIME TO REOPEN.
CHARLIE: IT'S ALL SUCH A LIE,
AND THEY'RE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO -- JUST
LIKE THEY PINNED EVERYTHING ON
COVID BEFORE, THEY'RE GOING TO
PIN IF EVERYTHING ON PUTIN NOW.
AND IT WAS SORT OF INTERESTING,
YOU SAW YESTERDAY BOTH THE WHITE
HOUSE AND NANCY PELOSI BOTH PUT
OUT THESE COMPLETELY BONKERS
BETWEENS YESTERDAY ABOUT HOW --
TWEETS YESTERDAY ABOUT HOW
INFLATION HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
SPENDING, WHICH IS JUST SORT OF
BREATHTAKING.
I I THINK MOST REGULAR AMERICANS
REALIZE THIS, AND I I THINK
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE SO SCARED AND
THEY'RE SO FURIOUSLY TRYING TO
PIN THIS ON ANYBODY ELSE OTHER
THAN THAN THEMSELVES, BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THAT THEY'RE GOING
OBEY IF ACE -- A PRICE FOR US.
JACKIE: A LOT OF AMERICANS DO
VOTE WITH THEIR POCKETBOOKS.
ONCE THEY START TO FEEL THIS,
THEY GO TO THE POLLS IN THE
MIDTERMS, AND THINGS MAY START
TO CHANGE, AND THIS
ADMINISTRATION KNOWS THAT.
GRIFF: IT'S AN OLD ADAGE OF
POLITICS, GRAB 'EM BY THEIR
POCKETBOOKS, AND THEIR HEARTS
CAN AND MINDS WILL FOLLOW.
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THIS PUTIN
PRICE TAG THING, I'VE BEEN
FILLING MY CAR UP, AND IT'S VERY
PAINFUL.
I'VE NOT HEARD ANY CURSING OF
PUTIN'S NAME, BUT I'VE HEARD A
LOT OF CURSING WHEN PEOPLE ARE
FILLING THEIR TANKS UP.
THEY MAY WANT TO ROLL OUT A NEW
BOGEYMAN, BECAUSE VLAD ISN'T
GOING TO STICK.
JACKIE: RACHEL, YOU MENTIONED
YOUR NINE CHILDREN.
WHEN YOU HAVE A FAMILY THAT
LARGE AND YOU'RE PAYING MORE FOR
GROCERIES AND GAS AND EVERYTHING
ELSE THAT THEY NEED, I MEAN, IT
MUST BE VERY DAUNTING.
RACHEL: IT IS.
BUT I TELL YOU, EVERY DAY THAT I
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT, I THINK ABOUT
THOSE ELDERLY PEOPLE ON FIXED
INCOMES, AND THEY JUST HAVE
NOWHERE TO GO.
THEY CAN'T GO TO THEIR BOSS AND
ASK FOR A RAISE, ASK AND OFTEN
THEY'RE ALREADY LIVING HAND TO
MOUTH AS IT IS, SO THERE'S
NOTHING FOR THEM TO DO, AND
THERE'S NO INDICATION AT ALL
THAT BIDEN WANTS TO CHANGE HIS
MIND AT ALL ON THINK OF THESE
POLICI